the United States has threatened to
impose further tariffs of more than a
hundred of more than eleven billion
dollars on EU products in response to
subsidies Brussels is paying to Airbus a
list of products subject to possible new
tariffs includes Airbus planes and
related products in the aviation sector
but also food products ranging from
swordfish and salmon to cheese olive oil
and wines the European Union meanwhile
has sued the United States for subsidies
paid to Airbus rival Boeing the World
Trade Organization says both parties
have broken global trade rules for more
on this let's cross over to Frankfurt
and our financial correspondent Conrad
booze and standing by Conrad tell us
who's right and who's wrong here well
Christophe as the WTO says both parties
have broken international trade rules
both parties have been heavily
subsidized over many many years and both
parties haven't been too eager to
implement WTO rulings over those years
but now it's the u.s. administration
which is changing the rhetoric Robert
light Taizo the trade representative
makes sure that you know those questions
over airplane makers are mixed with the
general American trade agenda which is
well an agenda of America first whatever
the cost whatever the political fallout
Conrad Airbus shares reached a
record-high on Monday how damaging is
today's news well shares an air bus at
the moment this morning here in
Frankfurt around about 2% lower we
should not forget that of course Boeing
at the moment is in deep trouble because
of the grounding of this 737 max
airplane this morning reports came in
from Indonesia where more of the family
families of the victims of this plane
crash Lyon airplane crash in October are
saying that they are going to sue Boeing
and from China it's been reported today
that a large leasing for
has put orders for this for this 737 max
airplane or on hold
conrad busan frankfurt thank you